should you buy the brand new M3 MacBook
Pro for
$1,600 or the previous M2 Pro for around
the same price because frankly this
machine does have a lot of advantages
over the new bass M3 Pro so in this
video we're going to be comparing a
bunch of different things to find out
including the speakers the displays
connectivity performance and more so
let's get started now the one thing
you'll notice right away is that we do
finally get the same new DES design
language of the 14-in model now for a
lower $1,600 price which is really nice
so the entire design everything's the
same we have basically the same display
with the same Notch but I am actually
noticing a little bit of a difference
this screen right here is noticeably
brighter than the other one and at first
I thought it wasn't turned up all the
way but it is and that's because this
display is now turned up to 600 nits on
the M3 machine compared to only 500 on
the M2 Pro even though all of the
features are the same with mini L 120 HZ
Pro motion that's actually a killer deal
that you get for 1,600 on this new one
now in terms of connectivity it's really
nice that the new Macbook Pro has the
max safe 3 Port so you have more
available plus it gets all of those
extra ports like HDMI and the SD card
slot the only issue is that they
actually removed one of the Thunderbolt
ports from this high-end design so on
the right side you don't even have one
which used to be really nice because you
can plug things in from the left and the
right but that is now gone on this base
machine and the weird thing is that even
though you have HDMI and Thunderbolt
ports you only can support One external
display on the M3 MacBook Pro which is
probably a M3 chip design limitation
compared to two external displays on the
M2 Pro which is one reason why somebody
might choose this older one compared to
the new one and we actually just tours
down this new M3 MacBook Pro definitely
watch that video after this one is over
and we have discovered that the base
model with 52 gigs of storage now comes
with dual nand chips which finally fixes
all of those performance issues we had
with
multitasking thank you apple and another
big deal is that this machine only has a
single fan even though it would have
been easier for Apple just to reuse the
same design with dual fans swap it over
they actually cut a fan out so we're
going to be testing the thermal
performance differences between these
two in just a minute and during the tear
down we also took a look at the speakers
and they look literally identical but
there's a chance that Apple tweaked the
software specifically for the new M3
machines so let's do a speaker
[Music]
comparison
and we have good news to my ears they
sound literally identical so it's nice
that you're getting these awesome
awesome speakers for 1600 and now
comparing the webcams this is the M3
MacBook Pro with the same 1080p webcam
as we have on the old M2 Pro we're just
looking at potentially any differences
in the noise levels or any software
tweaking potentially even the
microphones and then this is the
microphone and the camera on the M2 Pro
and I almost feel like there might be a
little bit less noise on this one than
the other one let me know your thoughts
down in the comment section below and
now let's move on to Performance
starting with the SSD transfer speed and
the first thing I want to mention is
that even though the M3 MacBook Pro only
has two Nan chip slots and both of them
are populated the M2 Pro actually has
four of them with two of them populated
so we might even see similar results
let's take a look and would you look at
that we have almost the same right speed
a little bit faster on the older M2 Pro
machine and almost identical read speed
2900 compared to
2859 so very very close essentially the
same SSD speeds but if you're planning
to upgrade your storage to one terabyte
or even more you actually going to get a
bigger benefit with the M2 Pro machine
because then it populates all four of
those nand chip slots and you're going
to get a lot faster speeds and now let's
get into geek bench 6 and testing the
performance now the important thing that
I do want to mention here is that this
machine comes standard for 1,600 with 8
GB of RAM while this one you could
probably get around 1,600 with 16 GB of
RAM and I know a lot of people were
online saying that 8 GB is not enough
this is going to be a terribly slow
machine but what if this actually
performs close to the M2 Pro in certain
tasks well well let's find out as we can
see right here we have the new Apple M3
chip and it clocks up to
4.04 GHz compared to the M2 Pro that's
3.48 GHz so that's 16% higher in terms
of the maximum Peak single core GHz so
let's go ahead and run the CPU test and
while it's going I do want to mention
the CPU layout of both of these the M3
has four performance cores and four
efficiency while this model of the M2
Pro which is bined has six performance
cores and four efficiency keep in mind
that you can actually upgrade the M2 Pro
to have eight performance cores double
of the new M3 and that's probably going
to be a lot faster now with either of
them and especially the 14-inch MacBook
Pro the best way to boost your
multitasking workflow is with the gemino
Dual stacked monitor from our sponsor
mobile pixels which is a game changer
for multitasking workflow allowing me to
drag Dr drop files and clips from the
top display right into my video editing
app on the bottom all while taking
screenshots from my video on my MacBook
saving me time and money and it's all
stacked onto this compact base which
saves death space and comes with a bunch
of extra ports so check out the Gino's
dual stack monitor using the link below
and there you go we have our score
starting with single core as you can see
the M3 is about 17.3% faster than the M2
Pro and that makes sense because they're
using brand new M3 performance cores
compared to the old M2 cores which they
were all the same across the entire
family now let's go down to multicore
and wow holy smokes guys this is
actually kind of crazy because the old
M2 Pro that has two more performance
scores is only 5% faster than the new M3
that you can get get brand new for
$1,600 this one was 2000 I can't believe
that Apple almost matched the
performance with two less performance
cores this is really really impressive
and honestly the performance of the M3
is more than enough for probably 85% of
the people out there and now I do want
to test the performance of the actual
web browsing which most people do on
their MacBooks and this is going to rely
a lot on the single core performance wo
this is really interesting because we
have basically the same score 491 492 I
wonder if it's actually using more
multicore performance nowadays with
Safari maybe that's some kind of an
update using more of the ecores or
performance cores I don't know but this
is actually really impressive you're
getting the same speed on both and now
let's get into the graphics performance
testing with the metal test and as you
can see the M3 has 10 GPU cores while
the M2 Pro the bin model has 16 of them
and there are a couple of other
differences like this M2 Pro which has
200 GB per second of memory bandwidth
compared to still 100 on the M3 so now
starting this Benchmark I do want to
mention that the M3 family of chips they
all have a bunch of new GPU features
including the new mesh Shader
architecture they of course have the
hardware rate tracing which is going to
be huge for 3D rendering they also have
the av1 decoder and the new Dynamic
caching feature so we might actually see
similar performance just with those new
features and some tests we have our
scores and this is actually very
interesting the M2 Pro with the 16 core
GPU is
67% faster than the M3 even though it
has
62.5% more cores 16 instead of 10 so it
looks like these new GPU cores are not
like that much faster at least in terms
of raw performance so let's do something
a little bit more serious this right
here is 3D marks Wildlife extreme
Benchmark in unlimited mode this is more
of a gaming test which could take more
advantage of those new GPU features
we've got our scores and we have 48.3
FPS for the M3 and 66.8 FPS for the M2
Pro that's about 38% faster so that's a
smaller difference this time so it shows
that the new GPU features are in fact
helping this one perform better than it
did before but it is still more worth it
to just get the M2 Pro and keep in mind
this is the bend 16 core GPU you can
upgrade it to the 19 core GPU but it is
going to cost a pretty penny I think
it's a $300 upgrade so you kind of have
to battle with the budget and now let's
get into thermal throttling testing with
the new cin bench
2024 and as you can see it looks like
the M3 chips performance cores are
running a little bit hotter you can see
up to 73° C just kind of idling compared
to about 36 degrees Celsius on the
performance course on the M2 Pro that
might be because the M2 pro has
basically two heat pipes going to two
different fans so it's kind of
dissipating more of the heat while this
only has a single fan with one heat pipe
that might be what's going on but let's
go ahead and run the cinebench 2024
multicore test right off the bat I am
seeing some differences here I'm seeing
that the M2 Pro is going up to 24.5
package power in terms of wattage this
thing just hit 20 21 but it's definitely
not using as much power as the M2 Pro
because of those extra cores however and
this is very interesting as you can see
the performance cores are only running
at
3.26 GHz that's because it doesn't hit
the peak when it's using all of them at
once it actually clocks down but the M3
they're running at
3.6
4 so it's actually quite a lot faster
the performance course on the M3 and of
course it's nowhere near the 4.05 GHz
Peak so it does get cut down but they
are running quite a bit faster oh
temperature 107° C it's been like less
than a minute it's already very very hot
while we're at 95° maximum on the M2 Pro
so the new M3 is running a lot faster
107° right there oh 108 I just saw it
hit 108 degrees that's actually Apple's
maximum acceptable temp it literally
will not allow it to go over 108 it'll
instantly throttle it and you can
actually see some spikes down in the
wattage and the clock speed to make sure
it does not go over 108 we're still at
let's see 99 98° on the M2 Pro so it's
staying a lot cooler and if we look at
this the left side fan is literally
idling 2300 RPM the right side is barely
on at 2500 while here we're looking at
4600 4700 it keeps ramping and ramping
up 4,800 and I can hear it I don't know
if you guys can hear that from our mic
5,000 I can audibly hear it already
nothing from the right side so if you
want a very nice and cool machine this
is already doing a lot better in terms
of the fan speeds I am seeing up to 27
package power almost 28 so it is
utilizing a little bit more right there
and I think the peak here was about 23
24 so more power usage on the M2 Pro and
I am noticing another difference the old
M2 efficiency cores are running at
2.42 in terms of the frequency and the
new M3 is running at 2.75 so that's
about 13 or 14% faster efficiency cord
clock speed which is going to help a lot
for taking care of a lot of those small
to medium tasks without having to turn
on the peores and it could help save
battery so it's been about 5 and 1/2
minutes running C bench 2024 I have our
thermal camera right here and I'm just
going to compare the maximum temps of
the actual chassis itself including
where the heat is getting dissipated so
on the M2 Pro we have right now a Max of
around 43° celsus right on the point
where the chip is at and right on the
display where it's venting about
4243 and then on the M3 look at that you
can actually see that it only has one
fan on that side and right where the
chips at we have about 34°
C and the display whoo yep 38° so it's
definitely getting rid of that heat
quite well this is actually a huge
difference because right there on the
the chip spot 34° C compared to 43 for
the M2 Pro that's a huge huge difference
in temp so this thing is definitely
getting a lot more hot since it's using
that extra wattage but dang I'm
impressed by that single fan on the M3
the test is finally finished and this is
extremely interesting in terms of this
CPU multi-core test because the M2 Pro
is now 19% faster than the M3 while in
geekbench it was only 5% faster so what
in the world is going on well I think
this is a test that kind of has a
massive task in terms of CPU rendering
so it has to tackle it and it has to
deal with the high temps and potentially
throttling and everything else so we're
seeing the M2 Pro perform a lot better
even though this new M3 has newer cores
and now let's get into something I'm
very excited for this is blender 3D
rendering this is the 4.0 beta which
does support rate tracing and hopefully
we should get a nice boost with the M3
let's render the image right here all
right so we did get an error using
Cycles so we decided to test out the new
EV engine which is set to support the
rate tracing I guess but we have our
results with both of them and guess what
the M3 is actually faster than the old
M2 Pro with 16 cores even though it was
like 53% faster
than the M3 in terms of RAW graphics
performance the m310 core is now beating
the 16 core M2 Pro so basically even
though the M2 Pro is better for gaming
and other RAW graphics tasks for 3D
rendering this thing is beating it out
and even without rate tracing it would
have been a lot slower like probably 20
seconds or slower so 3D renderers M3 is
for you and now let's move on to photo
editing with Lightroom Classic this also
uses the GPU for exporting so we're
basically going to export these 50 raw
42 MEAP pixel photos got my stopwatch
right here and let's go ahead and Export
now while this is running I do want to
mention that tasks like this especially
Lightroom classic is very very reliant
on the RAM and the M2 pro has 16 gigs
versus 8 so that's going to help and the
memory bandwidth also matters a lot
which again this thing has 200 compared
to 100 so let's see what we get and
there you go the M2 Pro just finish and
we still have a lot to go for the M3 wow
and there you go the new M3 just
finished and dang that is a big
difference the M2 Pro finished in a
minute and 3 seconds so 63 seconds
compared to a minute and
47 on the M3 so it looks like all those
GPU features everything is not helping
enough compared to that difference in
Ram and memory bandwidth it's all about
those two things for photo editing and
Lightroom classic in this case you're
definitely going to want to upgrade from
the 8 gigs of RAM over to 16 because
that is going to help a lot for this
type of task and by the way we did also
order one with 16 gigs of RAM and yes we
are going to test it so definitely
subscribe if you want to see that video
and now let's get into video editing
with Final Cut Pro we have an HC 5minute
file right here with a couple of Luts in
film grain and the main thing I'm
looking for here is if the brand new
encoders on the M3 chip which came from
the a17 pro are faster than the previous
ones fast enough to make this actually
export faster than a much faster M2 Pro
machine and there you go they're both
done and it looks like we have exactly
the same time 2 minutes and 20 seconds
so it looks like the M3 can keep up just
fine and it has the same encoders at
least for hvc and
h.264 as it did in the previous
generations so this is going to be
completely fine for most common video
editors out there and now with all of
that testing done and finished here is
my honest conclusion based on all the
performance that we got especially in
cinen showing 19% faster for the M2 Pro
especially for all the graph Graphics
tests and everything else the only
reason you'd probably get the M3 MacBook
Pro is if you need rate tracing and
you're doing 3D rendering that's going
to be faster but for everything else
honestly it looks like the M2 Pro is
actually better because it has much less
fan noise they're not as loud you have
lower temps you have basically the extra
Port you have the support for two
external displays instead of only one
and you actually have double the ram 16
gigs which is a huge deal so if you can
find this M2 Pro for around
$1,600 maybe even
$1,700 I'd say that you'd be better off
with the previous generation base M2 Pro
and then of course you might even get
lucky and get an upgraded version so
there you guys go the old M2 Pro is
better than the new base M3 so there you
guys go hopefully you enjoyed this video
and if you did definitely subscribe
above and check out our tear down and
Thermo thring video right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next
[Music]
one